est-ce qu'il y a des arts sur le coffre
dans mon bureau il y en a d'autres qui
arrivent
Justin Rosa on m'attend au bureau des
écoutes
seniors
on a quasiment tout l'intérieur et tout
l'extérieur sous surveillance de trafic
d'arbre et c'est lui contraste
sanglante
qu'est-ce qui pourrait arriver
un commando est en train de l'attaquer
des individus se sont introduits chez
lui c'est un vrai champ de bataille tu
fais plus un mouvement jusqu'à ce que je
t'ai rejoins
de merde
alors sur le feront il vient dans votre
direction
il arrive sur ta gauche je sais pas du
tout pourquoi tu m'as appelé il va s'en
prendre à toi encore des conneries je
l'ai sauvé à cause de votre de
liste s'arrête les coups de filles il y
a des flics à tous les niveaux Mike tu
fais quoi
on a une nouvelle cible
on savait pas ce qui nous attend
il va te détruire il faut savoir dire
stop alors ça te fait qu'elle est fait
savoir que tout le monde cherche à te
buter
[Musique]
est-ce que vous êtes leur complice